when Mad Max meets Burning Man  you get wasteland weekend  wasteland weekend takes place in the  middle of California's Mojave Desert and  is the world's largest post-apocalyptic  festival founded in 2010 this four-day  event sees nearly 3,000 desolation  enthusiasts attendees are required to  dress in the post-apocalyptic style  dress code and the costumes don't  disappoint  festival organizers design and build  elaborate set pieces but it's the  gearheads who attend that bring the  world of crumbling civilization to life  so as long as you're willing to commit  to the spirit at the end of the world  you'll be welcomed with open arms  [Music]  you  [Music]